And Java use packages to organize related classes. Now, everyone likes packages
particularly on Christmas, but in Java, we, we use them all year long. Classes
that have one responsibility, get put in one package and classes with a
different responsibility, in a different one. For example, you've seen the
package called java.util quite a bit. It contains, various utility classes such
as Scanner, ArrayList, Arrays, Random, and so on. That's one aspect of
packages, to group related classes together. There's another useful aspect, the
second aspect has to do with names. Unfortunately, in real life, names aren't
always unique. There may be more than one person called Fred. And if you refer
to Fred, they may all feel that they are the one. That's of course why last
names were invented. So that hopefully the first and last names are unique. Now
with people that's no longer the case, but with packages and classes it
actually is. A package name is intended to be unique around the entire world.
There's only 1 java.util package, and even though there may be other packages
that have a scanner class, java.util.Scanner is unique. And you can actually
reference in your programs, the scanner class as java.util.Scanner everywhere.
And say things like java.util.Scanner in equals new java.util.Scanner. That's a
little tedious, of course, which is why the import statement was invented. When
you say import java.util.Scanner, that means that from then on, you can drop
the family name, and just use Scanner. These two statements then mean the exact
same thing. This is the sole purpose of the import statement, to allow you to
use only the class name, or the first name so to speak, without having to use
the package name. Now let me show you, how to use packages in your own code. So
let's suppose that you have a class that you want to put into a package. All
you have to do, is put this statement starting with the word package, and then
the name of the package, on the top of the source file. Package names are
supposed to be unique, and most companies use their domain name written in
reverse order. Such as com.udacity instead of udacity.com. Because domain names
are guaranteed to be unique. Maybe you have your own domain name. But if you're
not. Udacity, in its infinite generosity, it will allow you to use theirs for
the following exercises. Now, when you want to use this class, you do what
you've always done, when you imported a class. You just use the import
statement, and then you get to use the class in the normal way. Now Sara will
practice this with you. And you get to reorganize the car pool classes.